على الرغم من كل ما يعيشه الكوكب من احداث
نحتفل اليوم ويحتفل العالم باسره باليوم
العالمي للسعاده ولكن السؤال الاهم يبقى
ما هي السعاده رغم ذلك يا ليت لدينا خبر
جيد السعاده ترتفع عبر العالم للسنه
الثانيه على التوالي ومصدر هذا الخبر هو
استطلاع اجرته شركه في 32 دوله المسح
العالمي كشف عن دوافع السعاده ووجد ان
الرضا عن الحياه يزداد في امريكا
اللاتينيه ولكنه ينخفض في العديد من الدول
الغربيه
وعلى الجانب الاخر بينما يكافح الناس من
اجل التواصل الاجتماعي يشعر الكثيرون
بالتشاؤم بشان مستقبل العلاقات ويقول واحد
من كل خمسه انه لا يوجد من يلجا اليه
للحصول على الدعم ومن جانب اخر دراسه
اقيمت لقياس مستوى السعاده عند الموظفين
فمتى يصبح الموظف اكثر سعاده التفاصيل مع
الزميله لميس ابراهيم
دراسه اجرتها شركه رابطها للتوظيف تقيم
فيها مستويات السعاده لاكثر من 12 الف
موظف خالصات الى امر بديهي الموظفون
الاكثر سعاده لديهم انتاجيه اعلى من غيرهم
الاستطلاع وجد ان الموظفين الذين لديهم
روابط وعلاقات جيده مع زملائهم في العمل
هم اكثر سعاده في وظائفهم بمقدار مرتين
ونصفا غيرهم من مسببات السعاده ايضا هو
شعور موظفين بالاستقلاليه والقدره على
اتخاذ بعض القرارات فيما يخصهم واداره
الوقت بمرونه وبحسب النتائج الموظفين
يفخرون بشركاتهم هم اكثر عرضه بثلاث مرات
للسعاده في العمل الدعم الايجابي والشعور
بالتقدير هو ثاني اكبر دافع لسعاده
الموظفين والتقدير يمكن ان يكون زياده في
الراتب او ترقيه او حتى رساله شكر قصيره
عبر البريد الالكتروني اما المحرك الاقوى
للسعاده فهو الشعور بالانجاز حيث يحتاج
الموظفين لشعور بان لديهم بصمه وتاثير على
الشركه على كل حال سالنا الناس في مصر اين
تجد السعاده الحقيقيه نتابع الاجابات
السعاده الحقيقيه في وجود زوجي وابني
ووالدتي طبعا سعاده الحقيقيه في ان انا
اركز مع اهدافي اكتر والنبي ابعد عن اي
حاجه بتضايقني يعني اقدر ان انا اخد
القرار الملاحظ ان الحاجه دي مضايقاني لا
لازم ابعد عنها واخد القرار يعني بلاقي
السعاده الحقيقيه لما احيانا لما بكون
لوحدي واحيانا لما بكون قاعد مع اصحابي بس
يكون صحابي انا بحبهم صاحب
في الاهل في
لمه جميله نعمل اي
حاجه حتى لو ان انت تراضي طفل او تطعم
حيوان حقيقيه في في ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في
الصلاه في
التسبيح في الذكر في قراءه القران فلما
اكون عندي اهداف وانجح في الحقيقه ساعتها
بلاقي السعاده في راحه البال في الرضا
في الاقتناع بما هو حاصل او مقدر بصراحه
ايه بالنسبه لي النجاح
كيف بتختلف اجوبه الناس لما بتساليها عن
السعاده كل واحد بشوفها من زاويه تختلف عن
الاخر وفي الاستوديو ينضم الينا او تنضم
الينا اخصائيه الارشاد والتنميه البشريه
فاتن عياش صباح الخير ست فاتن صباح النور
يا هلا يعني السؤال البديهي انه هل تختلف
السعاده من جيل لاخر لانه الجيل الشباب
مثلا يجدون السعاده بما لا يجده كبار السن
او الاكبر سنه مش رح نقول كبار السن
خليف السعاده ما الها عمر يعني في شخص
يكون كبير السن او اكبر سنه مثل ما حضرتك
ذكرت ويكون سعيد لانه نحن بنخلق سعادتنا
فهو مش الحقب اللي احنا فيها نحنا وين ما
كنا ممكن نخلق سعادتنا كلنا صغار صح ممكن
ما التواصل الاجتماعي ممكن بلاقوا سعادتهم
وممكن كبار السن او الاكبر سنه بيكونوا عم
يلاقوا السعاده بيعملوا شيء تطوعي عمل
تطوعي مثلا ممكن يلاقي سعادته بهذا الاطار
السعاده مش مربوطه بالسن
تحت الهواء كلمتيني عن هناك نموذج للسعاده
يعني الى عده مثل منقول مستويات هل لك ان
تخبريني اكثر عن شنو هذا نموذج لسعاد اكيد
وحلو اليوم باليوم السعاده العالمي يعني
ما فينا ما نذكر اللي اشتغلوا الاب للعلم
النفس الايجابي دكتور مارتن سيليغمان عمل
مثل موديل او نموذج بيحكي عن خمس اطر ممكن
الواحد يزيد السعاده فيها اول شيء بيحكي
عن البوزيتيف ايموشنز او كيف فينا نحن
كاشخاص نزيد
المشاعر الايجابيه ونخفف المشاعر السلبيه
لانه دائما نحن بشر في عنا السلبي وفي عنا
الاجابه فما فينا نقول بس لازم يكون عندنا
مشاعر ايجابيه لا بس كيف فينا نزيدها مثلا
نسمع موسيقى
نرقص نعمل اشياء بتسعدنا وهاي واحده من
الاشياء اللي نحن فيها تزيد معدلات
السعاده عند الانسان الموضوع الثاني او
القسم الثاني لانه هن خمس اشياء هي او كيف
فيني انا اندمج بشغله ما احس بدي اتطلع
على الوقت شو الاشياء اللي انا كموظف او
انسان ممكن اعملها بحياتي اليوميه اللي
ممكن تزيد سعادتك بطريقه انه انا اندمج
ممكن ادوات يعني مثلا في اشخاص بتسبح الي
بيسبح مبطل يطلع على الوقت او الرسمين او
المهتمين في اي شخص فينا في عنده شيء اذا
هلا سالتكم سمر وليس شو الشي اللي ممكن
انتم ما بتحسوا بالوقت اكيد بيطلع عندكم
شيء فاللي بيقولوا دكتور سالك من انه كيف
فينا نزيد من هذا الشيء
القسم الثالث هي الريليشن شيبس او
العلاقات لانه نحن مبرمجين انه نكون
عايشين مع بعض يعني ما فينا مثل ما
بيقولوا الجنه من دون ناس ما بتندهس صح
فكيف فينا نكون نحن محاطين بعلاقات
ايجابيه او علاقات
صحيه وليس علاقات سامه تفضل شوي ولكن هذا
يقودنا الى السؤال في كثير من الناس
بيكونوا مبسوطين في بيتهم في محيطهم
الاسري ولكن مش مبسوطين بالعمل مش حالتي
طبعا بس في ناس برضه العكس مبسوطين بالعمل
مش مبسوطين في جوهم الاسري كيف ممكن
الواحد يوازن انه تكون السعاده موجوده على
طول مش بس في العمل او في البيت